[Musique]
Chantal Hébert Michel David Sébastien
mauvais bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir on va
parler de la visite d'Anthony blinken
dans une seconde
et en trop du chemin Roxane parce que je
vais vous faire entendre monsieur
blinkin qui a eu une réponse fort
intéressante là-dessus en mettant ça
dans un contexte beaucoup plus large
mais commençons parce qu'il se passe
au parti libérale du Québec
madame anglaise qui perd ou qui éjecte
une députée Marie-Claude Nicole qu'on va
voir
député depuis 2014 dans Vaudreuil
c'est quand même quelque chose déjà pas
comme ça allait bien on va écouter on va
non on va pas écouter personne on l'a
écouté tout à l'heure et pardonner moi
c'est moi qui ai mélangé monsieur que tu
connais qui a dit j'ai pas le choix de
l'expulser parce que vous voulez rien
faire parce que l'acceptait pas de
s'occuper des transports Michel David
c'est la dernière chose que vous faites
espérer dans la main Glade
très certainement madame anglais d'abord
à 21 député on n'a pas les moyens en
perdant et puis madame Anglade va devoir
se soumettre à un vote de confiance là
il y a quelqu'un là qui va
s'activer je pense au sein du Parti
libéral pour miner la confiance de
Madame Anglade maintenant
madame Nicole c'est pas un bon soldat de
tout évidence là on peut pas dire je
pense au lendemain d'une érection où ton
parti est vraiment dans une situation
difficile où il y a peu de députés face
à plus de ministres de dire ah non moi
je veux être vice-président de
l'Assemblée sinon bon je comprends d'un
autre côté madame anglais devait se
montrer particulièrement diplomate je
pense dans ces circonstances ci et la
raison pour laquelle
expulsé il y a un mot que Monsieur tu
connais un prononcer en disant nous on
veut un cocus hermétique autrement dit
CRS à l'intérieur du caucus puis qui est
pas content il y a pas grand chose qui
se dit dans le caucus qui sortira pas à
l'extérieur et ça dans la situation où
les libéraux se trouve ça serait
vraiment une catastrophe à je comprends
mais ça règle pas le problème de Madame
anglais est-ce que vous dites c'est que
Monsieur tu connais ne pouvait peut-être
pas accepter qu'elle ne fasse rien ou
que ça soit le tout ou rien mais est-ce
qu'une la chef aurait pas dû trouver une
solution Chantal Hébert pour pas que ça
arrive en tout cas pas que ça se rende
jusque là en fait
bon alors premier résultat on n'est pas
en train de parler du cabinet fantôme du
Parti libéral qui est l'opposition
officiel puisqu'on est en train de
parler de l'expulsion d'une députée
deuxièmement ça fera pas un bon effet
auprès des membres sans égard à la
crainte de fuite le refus du poste
critique au transport qui est une bonne
offre en passant c'est pas c'est pas une
offre négligeable quand on connaît les
dossiers et on va en parler plus tard il
manque pas de viande dans le plat mais
néanmoins la journée du cabinet fantôme
dans l'état actuel des choses
ça vole la vedette au cabinet fantôme et
d'autre part je ne crois pas une seconde
que en expulsant une députée on va
mettre fin et le Sébastien Babel serait
mieux que moi on va mettre fin aux
fuites de ce qui se passe au caucus ça
tombe bien il est là
ça va bien oui merci c'est quand même un
gros coup pour un manga de elle était
pris devant un dilemme évidemment est-ce
que je la laisse faire ce qu'elle veut
où je la mais en même temps
arrêtez le pas pu régler ça derrière les
porte-closes puis trouver un aménagement
parce que là le résultat des courses
comme du Chantal on parle de ça puis ils
sont pas si nombreux se permettre d'en
perdre beaucoup voilà idéalement il
aurait pu trouver un compromis
évidemment il faut toujours pour faire
un compromis que l'autre personne
veuille bien dans le problème ici c'est
qu'on a qu'une seule version c'est celle
qui nous vient du Parti libéral de
Monsieur tu connais on lui a offert un
poste les transports comme papa pour les
transports et le refuser tout ce qu'elle
voulait c'était la troisième
vice-président de l'Assemblée nationale
de toute évidence madame Nicole je
voulais s'éloigner du caucus parce que
en étant troisième vice-président de
l'Assemblée nationale il aurait pas été
dans les débats partisans il a un siège
au curcus mais n'aurait pas été dans les
débats partisans avec le gouvernement
donc
quel était le choix de Madame Anglade la
garder au cucus allez avoir quelqu'un
qui était pas de bonne humeur et
peut-être faire en sorte que ces autres
membres du caucus soient de mauvaise
humeur aussi où l'exclure est posé un
geste d'autorité et la choisit le geste
d'autorité le problème c'est que c'est
peut-être la première fissure dans le
caucus contre le leadership de Madame
anglais et elle peut pas se permettre ça
à ce statique et leur parler à Michel
David d'un vote de confiance madame
anglais de voir qui qui qu'elle
souhaitait plutôt que tard
quand si vous je pense que c'est tout à
fait souhaitable pour Madame Anglade de
régler ce problème là dans un sens ou
dans l'autre au plus vite attendre à la
fin de 2023 comme c'est prévu
originellement bah ça laisse le temps à
beaucoup d'autres couler et à beaucoup
de
Marie-Claude Nicole de manifester leur
mécontentement et de deux choses là où
les sondages vont continuer à être
désastreux et les gens vont dire
ça va aller plus on va vouloir la
débarquer ou alors tout d'un coup si les
choses s'améliorent il y a des gens qui
actuellement ne pensent pas du tout à la
chefferie du Parti libéral qui pourrait
dire que ah ben finalement c'est
peut-être ça serait peut-être
intéressant alors peu importe le
scénario je pense madame anglaise doit
régler ça plus vite possible oui parce
que Chantal c'est inévitable la question
de son lit deux chiffres va revenir à
chaque deux semaines
la preuve étant ce dont on parle
aujourd'hui et
je fais pas partie des gens qui seraient
convaincus que de changer la date de la
devancer ou de la reculer ça aurait un
effet positif pour les deux chiffres de
Madame Anglade mais ça aurait un effet
positif pour la vie de ce focus parce
qu'on règlerait la question plutôt que
tard voilà visite du secrétaire d'État
américain à
Ottawa aujourd'hui il est temps il mange
à Tahoua il sera à Montréal le demain
donc visite de deux jours premier sujet
bon évidemment il va sans dire Ukraine
Iran l'article mais sujet dont ils ont
parlé Mélanie Joly lui assez abondamment
c'est Haïti qu'est-ce qu'on fait les
Américains qui aimeraient bien que le
Canada
organise prennent le leadership d'une
force militaire internationale policière
on écoute madame Joly qui est très
prudent on veut arriver là avec nos gros
sabots de façon voûtons aller là avec
nos gros sabots de toute façon on écoute
depuis longtemps le Canada est un très
bon ami d'Haïti et notre objectif c'est
de le lancement de le rester mais
d'améliorer encore notre relation il y
aura aucun décision qui vont être prise
sans l'implication des Haïtiens j'ai
toujours dit ça sera par et pour les
Haïtiens parce qu'au final c'est pour
leur bien parce que présentement c'est
le peuple qui souffre en Haïti alors
notre objectif c'est de les aider eux
dans les circonstances on doit
travailler en effet avec les Américains
avec beaucoup d'autres pays de la région
pour s'assurer qu'on aborde la question
de la sécurité la question humanitaire
et la question politique et je vous
dirai aussi ce qui est très important
présentement c'est qu'il y a cette
mission d'évaluation qui est là sur le
terrain
elle fait référence la ministre à une
mission canadienne actuellement ils sont
sur le terrain effectivement pour tenter
de comprendre les paramètres dans
qui pourrait
encadrer une future mission c'est
compliqué Chantal Hébert mais les
Américains aimeraient bien qu'on en
fasse plus en deux mots
voudraient franchiser la question
haïtienne au Canada pour s'occuper eux
de ce qui considère plus comme les vrais
affaires je dis entre guillemets c'est à
dire l'Ukraine etc la Chine Taïwan
est-ce que ça va fonctionner ça va
dépendre je crois parce que j'essaie de
décoder le point de presse Mélanie jolie
je vous ai ex ce que j'en déconne en
clair c'est le boss c'est juste pas
encore décidé et ça pourrait se décider
ou aller dans un sens ou dans l'autre et
un souper informel selon l'horaire
officiel avec le Premier ministre ce
soir et c'est là que ça va oui mais
comprenez que le Canada est beaucoup
sous pression pour l'état de ces
dépenses militaires et qu'on va se faire
se servir de cette carte là pour dire
vous faites déjà pas beaucoup au niveau
militaire le temps est autre mais vous
pourriez quand même gérer cette
situation là ouais Michel David
effectivement monsieur chrétien monsieur
Trudeau effectivement était pas très
chaud à une grosse opération canadienne
là-bas on a déjà été impliqué pas mal
les policiers aussi qu'est-ce que vous
avez décodé vous de ce point de presse
ça c'est clair monsieur Trudeau
n'a pas envie de s'embarquer là-dedans
comme depuis le début de son mandat il
fait le minimum en termes de coopération
internationale de mission paix etc et il
est clair que Monsieur blanken même s'il
a félicité le Canada pour sa grande
contribution dans toutes sortes de
dossiers il doit penser la même chose
que Brahim molronné qui a donné une
entrevue au devoirs cette semaine et qui
disait écouté un peu de mots là ça fait
dur la politique internationale du
Canada depuis depuis que Monsieur
Trudeau depuis qu'il est libéraux sont
arrivés là ils donnaient par exemple
puisqu'on parle de mission à l'extérieur
donnait l'exemple faisait la comparaison
entre 1993 l'année où il a quitté lui le
gouvernement et aujourd'hui et il disait
écouté quand je suis parti on avait
trois 1500 soldats militaires sur le
terrain il y a notre 35 actuellement
j'ai l'impression que aux États-Unis ont
fait exactement les mêmes calculs ouais
Sébastien puis Haïti il y a une urgence
urgence et pas à démontrer elle est là
elle est devant nos yeux mais il y a une
grande complexité par ailleurs aussi
c'est toujours difficile de décoder le
langage des diplomates on a l'impression
qu'ils veulent jamais trop s'avancer
toujours avoir une porte de sortie puis
quand Mélanie jolie dit il faut que la
solution soit par et pour les Haïtiens
elle veut dire quoi exactement on
comprend que le peuple haïtien est comme
otage de ce qui se passe en ce moment
avec les gangs de rue dans les rues mais
le gouvernement haïtien lui a-t-il
est-il assez solide pour gérer une
situation ou une aide qui lui serait
donnée a-t-il le contrôle de certaines
villes de certains ports aussi on a
l'impression que non et que donc
qu'est-ce qui est le plus important en
ce moment est-ce que c'est d'acheminer
de l'aide au peuple haïtien c'est à dire
un espèce de corridor humanitaire est-ce
que c'est une force militaire qui
pourrait être dirigée par le Canada on a
l'impression que c'est un peu monsieur
blanken demande au Canada c'était pas
saisi bien parce que si on si on met le
pied là-bas on sait on sait quand on met
le pied mais on sait jamais quand on va
en ressortir la minuscitant là qui était
la force des Nations Unies pour Haïti ça
a été extrêmement compliqué d'essayer de
rétablir l'ordre en Haïti donc
historiquement c'est bien beau y aller
mais on n'est jamais capable de régler
les problèmes de ce pays il est très
impopulaire et tout ça
Chantal parle de décoder des conférences
de presse et des réponses ça m'a fasciné
d'écouter monsieur blanken sur le chemin
Roxane on lui pose la question est-ce
que vous êtes est-ce que vous voulez ou
pas
renégocier l'entente sur les tiers pays
sur
à Mélanie Joly on en a parlé lui dit oui
on en a parlé mais là il dit attention
j'aimerais vous donner du contexte voici
le contexte
oui
[Musique]
là il ajoute oui oui il y a des endroits
particuliers autrement dit Michel David
ce qu'il dit c'est comprenez si vous
trouvez que c'est beaucoup de gens qui
entrent au chemin Roxane illégalement
imaginé ce que nous on vit dans le sud
par exemple imaginez les pressions
migratoires il y en a jamais eu autant
dit-il dans l'histoire l'humanité
autrement dit ne retenez pas votre
souffle ça peut être long cette
négociation là Michel ouais c'est un peu
c'est un peu comme Haïti c'est fait de
votre part
écoutez nous autres on est pris avec des
arrivées massives à la frontière sud
alors s'il y a des gens qui passent par
le chemin axam c'est ça de moins qui
vont s'installer chez nous c'est un peu
l'impression que j'ai eu en écoutant
monsieur blinken parce que de toute
évidence là j'ai pas senti du tout le
moins d'empressement de régler ou de
revoir l'entendre sur l'étape ici non
Chantal il dit il y a des feux ailleurs
et ça s'inscrit dans un contexte
beaucoup plus
[Musique]
des tonnes de gens qui transit par les
États-Unis et qui viennent de partout si
vous enlevez cette entente là êtes-vous
capable de les gérer à vos frontières à
vos postes réguliers de frontières parce
que c'est ça que ça veut dire et là on
parle d'un pays le Canada que de la
difficulté à gérer des passeports alors
c'est facile de dire on va régler la
situation puis ils vont tous passer par
des postes réguliers parce qu'il y avait
plus d'entendre sur les tiers mais
quelque part
ce qu'il dit c'est attention vous avez
une digue avec un trou moi je vous dis
enlever la digue et vous allez avoir une
marée c'est ça et puis il dit Sébastien
vous rendez pas compte de combien de
gens dont on parle c'est énorme les flux
migratoires n'ont jamais les pressions
n'ont jamais été aussi fort alors
avant d'enlever votre trou et oui
peut-être malaisant peut-être pas
pratique mais imaginez ce que ça
pourrait être Sébastien en fait on a
l'impression qu'il est presque content
qu'il y ait des migrants qui passent par
les États-Unis qui a bossé au Canada par
le chemin Roxane que ce soit
relativement facile de faire évidemment
sur une fraction des gens qui arrivent
aux États-Unis mais peut-être qu'on
devrait se questionner sur
les endroits d'où ils partent
l'instabilité politique le peu de
perspective que ces gens-là ont est-ce
qu'on est capable de faire quelque chose
plutôt que d'essayer toujours de chez
moi de patcher le problème c'est un défi
beaucoup plus grand que d'essayer de de
régler des ententes entre les États-Unis
et les Canada je boucle la boucle avec
Marie-claude de Nicole il reste deux
minutes elle aurait eu c'est la vague
accepté les transports un gros sujet
pour la rentrée le pont Hippolyte lui
Hippolyte Lafontaine la fermeture la
ministre on a vu des images est allé sur
place il y a de la matière Michel David
il y aura eu il y aurait eu de la
matière
compliqué pour la ministre ça aurait été
du bonbon pour pour Madame Nicole j'ai
l'impression le troisième lien mais ça
c'est dans l'immédiat c'est le dossier
qui va monopoliser la tension en matière
de mobilité et les solutions qui sont
avancées par le gouvernement là où
proposait par Madame Guilbaud tout le
monde sait bien que ça règle le repas
grand chose là et que mécontentements va
croire avec l'usage si je faisais
par exemple et si on en vient parce
qu'on demande forcer les le voyagement
sur l'eau
imaginez les conservateurs comment de
Monsieur Duhem qui serait content
d'avoir encore une entrave à la liberté
alors non c'est vraiment le manquer
madame Nicole
qui va souffrir de cette situation là
alors c'était effectivement du bonbon
pour n'importe qui qui est critique au
transport Sébastien conclusion ce
dossier là on se croise les doigts tout
le monde pour la semaine prochaine on
verra l'usage oui on passe on savait que
Geneviève Guilbaud serait la ministre du
tunnel on pensait pas que ce serait ce
tunnel là parce que ce serait plutôt le
troisième lien donc elle en a plein les
baskets en parfum merci à vous trois
bonne soirée au revoir
[Musique]
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI